i want to look at a clip from uh i
believe it's yesterday's joe rogan
program joe rogan interviewed a friend
of our show josh zepps very good guy
i've been on his show doesn't mean josh
and i agree on everything uh but i've
always
known him to be a a good guy
josh appeared with joe rogan and the
topic came up of myocarditis risk for
young men from the covet vaccines
important topic
uh joe rogan was presented with the
evidence that the risk of myocarditis
from having covid
is significantly higher than the risk of
myocarditis
from the vaccine in both cases
most everybody recovers no problem but
the risk of myocarditis is higher if you
get covid than if you get the vaccine
in real time you will see
really disappointing goalpost moving and
techniques from joe rogan that are
really typical
sadly of the people that email me and
are clearly set in their ways and don't
want to have their minds changed so
let's take a look at the conversation
this is this is interesting it's also
really sad pointing myocarditis more
common after covet 19 infection than
vaccination but is this what uh oh so
first it now here's a study
the study already says myocarditis is
more common from
than from the vaccine so that already
goes against what joe rogan has been
told and i'll show you part of where he
got it children
uh
yeah we're talking about young people so
um rogan now says well i'm really i'm
talking about it within young people
only boy is aged under 30 after this is
what it says here so as you can see the
study as as uh
jamie points out
includes up to age 30
and that includes younger and that
includes up to all the way up to 30.
with children is the issue well no rogan
says i'm only concerned about children
here we're talking about 15 year olds
well we're talking about young children
12 to 17. 12 to 17 more like develop
myocarditis with three months of
catching covet at a rate of 450 cases
per million infection this compares to
67 cases of myocarditis per milliliter
joshua points out correctly
look at the 12 to 17 age group is that
young enough joe even among 12 to 17
your risk of getting myocarditis from
covid
is about eight times higher than from
the vaccine
time following her second dose of fiber
pfizer yeah so you're about eight times
likely to get myocarditis from getting
covered than from getting the vaccines
that's interesting that is not what i've
read before but also it's like
when even when we're reading these
things it's like what are we getting
this from this well this is a
peer-reviewed study and there's numerous
peer-reviewed studies that have been
done on this so so
notice the goal post shifting it's okay
now there is a claim that the risk is
actually higher of myocarditis from
covert than from vaccines but can we
really trust what we're reading well
yeah actually we can from there's a
report but even
from the vares reports when they report
this stuff it's like the amount of
people that report the um like it's the
under reporting so now there's a new
thing which is rogan says
even if you consider veyers which is not
even verified
rogan says it stuff is being under
reported so
this study
is based on under reporting to vayor's
when we know the real issue with vares
is actually over reporting completely
unconfirmed reporting notice the goal
post shifting that takes place depending
upon who you ask and like what it is
it's either one percent under okay
so um
this is uh unfortunately
this is what happens a lot of times when
you when you have these types of
conversations with people now i had this
conversation not long ago i have a
family member who works in pediatrics
and i said before i got my third dose
you know i'm kind of freaked out because
now when you sign up for your third like
i'm the most pro-vaccine person when i
signed up for my third dose it had me
understand it said do you understand
that there is a risk of myocarditis and
it just freaked me out and the person i
was talking to said yeah but david
remember
the risk to people your age
from covid of myocarditis is higher than
from the vaccine and here's studies that
we've been looking at and i looked at it
and i said oh you're absolutely right
right that that makes sense um and a lot
of this goes back to that uh peter
mccullough appearance with joe rogan
where mccullous was talking about
vaccine-induced myocarditis and did not
mention by the way
the risk of covet-induced myocarditis is
dramatically higher than from the
vaccine so i wish that joe rogan had
received this information differently
really nice job by josh zepps and as
i've said before i welcome any
opportunity to go back on and talk to
rogan about exactly this issue
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowl soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below